[Musique]
j'ai failli le dire Fatou je me suis
retenu tu as donc cette référence des
Pokémon de la Team Rocket bravo bravo
Fatou pour la ref ça démarre fort où ça
redémarre fort et du coup on avait une
finale de dames entre Magnus et
eprague il nous reste aussi
vente forest Ken finale avec une qualité
de moins mais qui a les pions pour
compenser
et des pièces actives et enfin bouquet
chez rognon je t'avais dit que ça
devrait faire nul cette finale de tour
normalement c'est nul pendant ce temps
là tout à l'heure on a vu aussi tant
qu'on y est donc la nul attendue de
Wesley Sow et d'abdosa t'auras
qui permettra de s'attendre sans doute
de garder lead du tournoi si Guiri est
seul psy guéri et Carlsen font bien
nulle on a vu la belle nulle de Vincent
Kemer ton chouchou contre
[Musique]
et Max doudou a bien gagné contre
reggaizi de même que Richard rapporte
qui a battu dans le zaynaut digne
c'est reparti on va aller voir ce qui
s'est passé un petit peu dans la finale
de dame est-ce que ça va faire nul très
prochainement ou non cette partie entre
Magnus et Prague sa joie assez vite
alors il y a eu des échecs assez logique
dans ce genre de situation moi j'ai 7
permettant de tenir l'option F7
G8 on reste au contact projet 7 dame G3
damn D1 les petits coups d'échec roissez
5 attention
Praga a pris le pion H5 mais là
maintenant en fait je me dis que ça va
ça va durer cette position parce que
c'est très déséquilibré
oui
peut-être peut-être du tout ou rien en
tout cas ça va forcer ça va passer On
n'est pas couché avec cette partie à mon
avis Magnus va pousser au maximum
l'histoire c'est que on a un pion passé
potentiel voire deux relativement
facilement il faut bouffer ça ou faire
un cadre B5 mais on aura au moins un et
dans les finales de dames ce qu'on dit
Fatou c'est qu'il faut avoir les pions
passés avancés c'est le camp qui a le
pion passé avancé qui va dominer s'ils
sont éloignés c'est encore mieux éloigné
du roi adverse éloigné du roi noir c'est
le cas son droit noir et à moitié coupé
ici donc c'est dangereux pour Prague
très dangereux
ok ça va le fil rouge
on va aller voir on va aller voir tout
cela franchement
ça va être très très tendu ça te signale
de dame tout à l'heure ça paraissait
beaucoup plus amusant on va revenir
dessus de toute façon on va aller voir
van Forest et guéri on va faire un petit
tour des échiquiers est-ce que vente
Forest a réussi à améliorer sa position
ou non donc tour à trois logiques on
bloque de fois 4 tour des 4 ma x
pourquoi pas roi F6 et food étroit c'est
les d'ailleurs les détours des cadres de
se libérer faire fout les trois et
pouvoir pousser le 4 tours
et peut-être prochainement une nulle
avec cette histoire de harcèlement
c'est possible ouais ça laisse
penser que ça peut répéter
on peut expliquer pourquoi un peu l'idée
de le roi a besoin d'être là pour
accompagner les pions et pas laisser
rentrer le roi adverse donc
la petite manœuvre de guéris c'est je
passe ma tour derrière puis je vais
empêcher tout droit de monter
pour être au contact j'ai pas envie que
la tour Vienne en deux
et
donc là je suis entre roi G3 revenir et
ainsi de suite
donc on E3 jouer d'ailleurs
et ok on va arriver sur sur quelque
chose d'assez
c'est normal la séance voilà
ok on fait on fait le tour de façon on
va suivre un fil rouge
vous aussi mais on va suivre un fil
rouge là final de dames de Carlson
rognon une partie un peu moins
savoureuse
on a dit que ça devrait être nul parce
que si le roi part on peut faire tomber
la loi je parle du roi blanc donc le roi
noir va rester ici autour de ses pions
et la Tour Noire au contact de B2
une des chances pratiques c'est
peut-être de ne pas faire tout reprend
un cas tout reprend B2 qu'on sait nul
donc du coup ce que je ferai et je pense
que c'est une des idées
ici de goucash c'est de garder le
matériel donc il faudrait essayer de
passer le roi de bouffer sur un 4 pour
garder les deux pions ici
mais ce que je peux passer
je viens de faire F5 il va peut-être
faire
il y aura tout G2
et je vais essayer de passer un roi des
cartes etc on va voir voilà ce que
j'essaierai de faire enfin tout si je
veux gagner à tout prix
aller bouffer ce plan là le roi parce
que cette tour là elle est astreinte à
défend à pas défendre mais après c'est
le pion B2 pour défendre virtuellement
depuis un cadre de manière indirecte
elle a beaucoup de fonctions quand même
exactement
j'ai trois G4 j'ai trois peut-être mais
ça voilà pour l'instant
et du coup mon idée c'est de faire trop
de partir
voilà ce que je veux essayer en tout cas
ok tourgé de jouer
ça fait cinq
donc ben je voudrais bien alors roi des
cinq il y a peut-être tours 2 peut-être
3D 4 est-ce que j'ai le droit c'est
chaud parce que roi des quatre tours
c'est nerveux
comme ça surtout reprend les trois j'ai
tout reprend la 4 alors que si je fais
roi des 4 tours projet 3 j'ai pas tout
reprend un 4 il y a l'enfilaire d'ici
donc je fais roi des 5
tours G3
c'est chaud mon histoire parce que ah
oui tu reprends j'ai trois maintenant
j'ai peut-être le droit de prendre donc
tu peux pas vraiment prendre donc je roi
des 5
est-ce qu'il peut pousser acharnement
tout à fait raison il va falloir essayer
de penser à ça mais pour l'instant il
peut pas pousser à acheter celui-là je
pense
mais tu veux pas croquer parce qu'à tout
reprendre à 4
donc là je vois bien tours c'est de
revient
et là
je voulais jouer au roi des quatre
taper la tour et après partir comme ça
ok il y a du travail encore dans cette
pause en tout cas je crois que c'est
vraiment très intéressant ce qui est en
train de nous montrer Google
de manière un peu légère tout à l'heure
je pensais vraiment que ça allait faire
nul bon je l'influencer en plus par la
jauge sans doute que c'était nul quand
même
il fallait trouver quelque chose et
en fait il a joué des coups un petit peu
neutres les von a rognan
et maintenant il y a ce qu'il est de
Google finalement qui est de ne pas
prendre en 4 de préférer garder les deux
pions c'est très bien vu et maintenant
d'essayer de passer le roi pour aller
croquer le pion dans de bonnes
conditions si on a les deux flèches et
qu'on arrive à pas prendre l'eau de trop
à l'ail droit on devrait gagner
donc il y a vraiment il y a vraiment du
jeu et un intérêt à travailler cette
position
non c'est super c'est super
du coup
on va aller voir notre grand format je
pense si tu es d'accord tout
oui
je cherche un quelque chose avec
et prendre j'ai après te dire j'ai passé
et peut-être
j'ai envie de pousser hache et de me
faire monter mais dans quelles
conditions on peut le faire
et
peut-être
faut faire gaffe à ce point quand même
ça va être chaud
prise de risque
les comment ils devaient jouer cette
finale alors un gros E4 leur dit
annoncer nul est-ce que il se trompe ou
est-ce qu'il change
il aurait dû chercher le contre jeu
directement par tour G2
OK
2 F5 c'est quasiment la pression de la
partie en fait
il a joué les coups je crois que ça joue
très bien juste tourage de tour B4
ça ressemble à ce qu'on aurait pu avoir
tour des deux
oui mais alors on aurait la même
position tout à l'heure
le roi est mieux placé en 4.3 en fait
parce que je peux toujours en dessin
alors je sais pas comment on est arrivé
à ça mais on a réussi à faire un tour de
passe-passe donc fallait faire tourger
deux pour le roi revienne
tour des deux pour le bloquer
ok F5
tourrage 2 tour B4 3 F6 qu'est-ce qu'il
a raté alors juste pour comprendre
Tourbec à 3 F6 il a pas saisi tout de
suite oui en fait il s'est un peu
précipité sur waf6 il aurait peut-être
mieux fait de jouer le tourgé de d'abord
et ça fait nul on peut faire un petit
point sur le score
si vous voulez des quatre parties
terminées
donc Fabiano Caruana Vincent Kemer match
nul
so weisler douce à torov ça nous
intéresse particulièrement puisque en
fait était en tête et wesleo il était 4e
enfin troisième execo avec avec Magnus
je vais vous dire des bêtises en faisant
toute tête
oui c'est bien ça du coup ils ont fait
match nul partit très plate Richard
rapporte abattu dingleren même si ça
nous intéresse moins grosse performance
du joueur du néo joueur roumain
et du coup max zouglou a battu e regga
easy voilà et il nous reste une finale
de dames de Carlsen une finale de tour
de bocage contre un rognan Carsen est
opposé à pragnamanda fait souffrir
pragnamanda depuis le début de la partie
mais prennent un endroit sort une grosse
partie et Vans forest guéri le duel des
Néerlandais
maintenant guéri qui va essayer
peut-être de presser un petit peu mais
on pensait que ça allait faire nul voilà
pour vous vous donnez
les histoires de ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui et maintenant au classement
pour l'instant on a d'où ça Torah qui a
8 points avec un point d'avance sur
gearim et qui n'a pas encore fini sa
partie et un vrai point d'avance contre
wesleo donc voilà il y a que guéri
maintenant qui peut rattraper je pense à
d'où ça torov dans dans ce tournoi
va avoir les blancs demain pour finir
du coup alors on est parti on revient
il fallait jouer tour G2 ici dès le
début de la finale mais il y avait roi
F3 ouais c'est très dur tour G2 c'était
quand même mieux parce que
F3 tour des deux
F5 pour fermer la boutique
tourage 2 si je vois
je mets ça à plusieurs fois j'essaie de
trouver
4 donc si je tourbé 4
il y a toujours 4 comme on serait
retombé dans la même
chose jamais non non on va y aller et
donc est-ce que ça a été joué j'ai pas
l'impression
je vais recharger pour voir
alors est-ce que
est-ce que
non il n'a pas joué encore roi des 5
pourtant qui paraît vraiment de le coup
un peu basique mais Google je prends son
temps pour bien tout gérer ok on y
reviendra et on va aller directement
[Musique]
on va aller directement sur cette finale
de dames qui promet avec un très joli
coup là j'ai l'impression de jouer
Magnus a joué fort logiquement
à 4
personnes
je voulais jouer il voulait jouer sans
doute
des motifs avec B5 ou AB6 on va prendre
un 6 et là on lui demande de prendre une
décision genre à 5 et là peut-être que
je vais pouvoir tenir ma pause
puis aussi il faut analyser d'un projet
de non mais il est quand même beaucoup
mieux Magnus c'est c'est plus facile en
tout cas de jouer sa position même si
l'ordi 01 ou égal 00
une dame bien je pense que c'est très
bien le choix de toute façon
c'est très bien est-ce que tu peux aller
chercher le pion avec le roi
oui mais je dois solutionner le problème
de 8 essence
je sais pas si
on peut ne pas le perdre du poids ne pas
le perdre sans être sûr de pousser par
derrière
et puis voilà
et maintenant peut-être envoyer
du pion
de tâches
voilà ce que je verrai comme suite
Laurier à peu près
mais tendu faut pas ça fait peur les
finales de dames à chaque fois
on a Magnus à l'écran il cherche mais
c'est pas facile il s'en rend bien
compte c'est sûr
faut être précis le premier le plus
précis possible au final de manière
générale et là aussi si on veut éviter
la nul les perplexes et si on le trouve
un plan de gain sur
donc vous pouvez aussi il faut aussi du
temps
demain demain
Forez donc ça sera très intéressant et
dirige aura un rapport en forme et
galvanisé par sa victoire contre
dingueren pas facile
[Musique]
nul économique pour Abdou aussi dans la
dans le même style de ce que tu dis
Laurie c'est quand même pas me coulos
pour lui ils ont des jours de repos mais
comment on l'a dit c'est un très long
tournoi donc
la situation naturelle quand vous faites
un 13 rondes j'en ai pas joué beaucoup
dans ma vie mais déjà des 11 rondes je
trouvais ça long mais le seul tournoi
que j'ai pu jouer en 13 secondes j'avais
trouvé ça extrêmement long
le Top 12 ou le Top 16 c'est combien de
ronde
en fait quand c'est top 12 c'était 11
ronde et du coup ils ont laissé ce
format là en Top 16 avec un système de
deux poules des calibres
mais les compétitions par équipe c'est
vraiment très différent parce que
souvent dans ces équipes là on vient
avec un effectif important
la différence par rapport à une
compétition individuelle c'est qu'on
n'est pas obligé de jouer tous les
matchs
donc du coup c'est souvent le grand
classique des 11 rondes c'est en fait 9
sur les 11 ça peut être moins mais en
général c'est ça dans les équipes et il
y a quelques joueurs qui en font moins
mais
[Musique]
bon c'est parti et Magnus il a fixé
il a joué à 5 pour garder un maximum
d'options et passer un moment
alors là faut être précis sans doute
hein
ça tombe bien il est
est-ce que Prague va réussir
ouais ils s'en fiche et même si je
défends comme ça je ferai B5 et sur
apprends B a 6 et on y va le but c'est
de se créer le pion passé à le plus
avancé possible
et c'est vrai que je mets du temps à
mettre en marche les trois pions là
bon le coup qui me vient à l'esprit
c'est Dame j'ai parce que c'est roi B6
au prochain coup
donc je fais dame j'ai un comme ça il y
a la paroi B6
donc dame Descartes logique
donc on va jouer dame Descartes
la dame pro G2
du sens parce que je crée le pion passé
et là je dirais G4 Givet je peux faire
Damas 8 mais c'est très passif il y aura
B5 en plus je suis vraiment pas sûr d'un
coup comme ça je préfère
ok
on sait pas trop
je trouve que c'est très lent je suis en
retard par appion par rapport au G3 donc
j'irai B5
apprend B
et A6 voilà voilà ce que voudrait c'est
pas bon ce que j'ai joué tu vois il faut
être précis je pense que là ah si ça a
gagné quand même
je sais pas
en fait ça c'était bien B5 c'était
logique en tout cas et puis on prend B
il faut pas le faire ça accélère d'un
tempo si tu veux je comprends maintenant
bon c'est vrai qu'apprend B c'est un
coup un peu mécanique et en fait je fais
à 600 d'un coup du coup donc ça oui en
fait c'est Dame D8 à 6 sans doute le
gain je sais pas mais sur apprendre
pour parer ça
en tout cas même là on peut on doit
pouvoir faire nul comme ça peut-être
j'ai trois
vous imaginez le bordel ça va être au
tempo prêt il y a plein d'échec dans la
position c'est dangereux ces positions
ok
mais ça va être comme ça c'est quelque
chose comme ça que veut Magnus est
pragmatique
c'est logique en tout cas donc sur A5 je
voudrais bien dame G1
il a du temps
il est dans six coups il récupère un
quart d'heure encore
donc ça peut être ça peut être très long
ces histoires de finale
soit un traquage mais je pense que la
consultante que je veux aussi
ça peut-être pas durer tant que ça alors
que je veux bien les voir là pendant que
PRAG réfléchit parce que maintenant on a
compris cette dame G1 la nuit le salaire
logique quand même les coups vent de
Forest guéri
est-ce que ça répète ou un c'est les
blancs qui ont réussi à
j'ai l'impression que guéri il a voulu
continuer ah non c'est ventes forest qui
a voulu continuer pardon
répétition
c'est pas grand-chose F3
G2 c'était quoi le
bon c'était tour des cinq
et tu me fais ça nul ok non j'arrive pas
à passer alors c'est quoi pourquoi leur
dyslexique là ils nous dis 0,5 un petit
une petite poussette pourquoi il nous
dit ça Laurie
a du mal à comprendre toutes les parties
[Musique]
parce que là il y a de cela et puis
vraiment ils nous rendent dedans
je vois pas l'ordi
5 3 F4 on travaille il a raté ça leur
donne en fait Jordan veut faire nul
je pense
il dit une tête
on a quand même
[Musique]
l'option de moins enfin le pion de moins
oui on a froupion contre tour
c'est tentant il peut retrouver encore
si je regarde
la même chose
[Musique]
ils vont répéter la vraisemblablement
parce que
Jordan n'y croit plus il a que cette
manœuvre là donc j'ai vérifié un pour
voir je comprenais pas pourquoi j'ose
j'ai petit avantage regardez c'est
magnifique
O2 parce qu'à tourgé trois qui menaçait
ton G3 maintenant et là je me NAS tour
des cinq échecs 4 et l'idée de passer
avec mon bloc de pions centraux et là on
avait dit si on arrive à pousser le 5
c'est notre histoire très très beau
dernière tentative dans cette position
et ça faisait peur de laisser ça
j'ordonne a bien fait de laisser cette
config parce qu'il peut faire mal
dans ce cas-là
la seule chose à voir c'est encore une
fois le contre jeu avec le pion a
exactement parce que les pions
pas si facilement mais
si tu as envie que les pièces blanches
aller voir ailleurs
il y a moyen tout à fait non tout à fait
donc du coup
c'est quand même très intéressant ce
qu'on voit là c'était pas si simple les
deux joueurs réfléchissant c'est pas
comme c'était facile pour eux
évidemment ça se trouve à régler blanc
en plus Jordan pourrait faire mal à la
niche guéri alors là si Jordan venait va
faire mal à niche guéri le tournoi et il
serait quand même
bien plié très clairement il suffirait
d'une nulle d'abdosaures donc pour le
spectacle franchement on peut que
souhaiter
que Aniche ne perd pas pour avoir une
chance demain mais il est en difficulté
est-ce que le Jordan s'en est rendu
compte on va voir on va voir
la pression un petit peu
est-ce que le Jordan veut jouer pour le
gain est-ce qu'il se rend compte qu'il
est mieux parce qu'on a l'impression que
le placement des pièces noires est
optimum sur les cases noires et en fait
on arrive à trouver ce tour des cinq et
attention
le coup C6 n'est jamais extraordinaire
il y aura toujours des six ma tour est
bien passé sur les faiblesses adverses
avec des menaces de maths non non ça on
va on va devant d'ennuis
c'est pas logique de jouer comme ça
on verra alors du coup
pas il n'a toujours pas joué contre Manu
ça peut durer ou pas ou faire nulle très
rapidement tu vois on est vraiment dans
l'incertitude des fois Fatou tu connais
bien cela on a l'impression ça va être
des fois hyper long hier je pensais
rapporte
ils ont fait nul en deux coups une
position où il y avait encore pas mal de
pièces goukia charognan et bah ça y est
le plan de Fatou est en marche
et ça va être ultra chaud
parce que de toute façon si tu perd ses
deux pions là faut trouver du contre je
fais tout comme tu l'as dit tout à
l'heure donc on y va on balance à 5 et
on fait on fait un pion passé nous aussi
on trouve du contrôle jeu
née
à tourbey 4 Roy F6 roi F5 puis on F5
pardon bref 6 plus F5 tour G2 roi des 5
bien joué et là les vannes il se dit
attention il y a ce plan là bon je vais
te foutu il faut que je réagisse tout
prend G3 ça laisse enfin tu reprends un
4 sans perdre B2
pour là c'est un non sens
tomber carte qui gagne qui gagne
directement donc on va pas faire ça
donc à chaque et on y va
bon là il y aura prise on va pas laisser
H4
non je vais pas laisser H4 c'est trop
dangereux
et là on voit
il faut que je bouge 4 pour ça il faut
que je fasse trois points je pense
et ça et ça et ça et ça en contre en
contrepoids
[Musique]
maintenant est-ce que je joue B4 par
exemple B4 B5
le pion il a vraiment une super utilité
enfin tout c'est si un jour la tour bon
je sais pas en jour allez un coup comme
G4 si un jour la tour se met derrière
j'ai tourné 4
qui est génial en thématique le pion à 3
c'est vraiment bien foutu cette config
[Musique]
on en a parlé dans l'ouverture mais en
finale
je suis de la partie ou en finale elles
ont d'autres placements idéaux et donc
là en l'occurrence derrière le pion
passé on la met comme ça ça nous permet
de pousser pousser pousser jusqu'à la
dame et c'est plus difficilement
arrêtable
il se trompe pas alors là apparemment
vous voyez la jauge dit nulle mais
pas trop comment on va faire ça
c'était l'idée on a dit B4 c'est pas nul
c'est juste la jauge qui pète un câble
mais non non c'est pas nul du tout je
vous l'assure c'est même peut-être
gagnant maintenant un BK c'est en plus
c'est un coup facile à trouver
c'est pas facile G4 c'est pas illogique
je vois bien cette suite de partie voilà
on fait tourner trois c'est une
possibilité mais c'est dangereux parce
que le pion va vite aussi
5 G4 B5 on verra cette petite peut-être
salut
j'ai trois il faudra jouer 3 à 8
c'est au tempo prêt qui va être perdant
[Musique]
en tout cas il va falloir une défense de
faire de Levana rognan s'il veut rester
en vie dans cette partie ça me paraît
beaucoup plus facile à jouer côtéh on
verra bien mais si je devais me
prononcer sur cette finale le riz même
si l'ordi a l'air de dire ouais on va
réussir à faire nul en étant très précis
je pense qu'il va craquer eleven à Royan
je la trouve très difficile
et salut à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent
le stream a coupé du coup ben voilà on a
perdu un peu de monde mais en tout cas
normalement il devrait plus y avoir de
problème et on va retourner peut-être
voir 45 toujours pas jouer Prague il est
inquietra quand même il a six coiffe à
faire il a la pression il a maintenu sur
son phase de lui qui le presse vous
voyez d'ailleurs que les top players ils
continuent jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout
il pose des problèmes comme hier hier
c'est pas passé Magnus il compte bien
revenir la charge aujourd'hui
et attention en cas de victoire Magnus
peut encore revenir
toujours dangereux Magnus
et pourquoi pas pour un retour en cas de
gain il finit il est à 7,5
c'est bon mais il faut qu'il gagne déjà
cette finale de dame
il faudra un peu dette de Prague si
Prague est parfait ça va être dur
ce qui est beau c'est qu'il a il a
dominé un moment et puis il lâche le il
lâche le truc et puis finalement on dit
coucou plus tard il reprend et il se bat
il peut faire nul mais non il veut pas
il a une force de
la même position on y revient pas par
contre ça à jouer chez vent de Forest
plutôt que de se contenter de la nul
avec trois il a pas trouvé le plan de
leur dire roi E3 fois ou deux mais il a
joué ses 6
[Musique]
avec quelle idée il veut jouer
il veut éviter les C6 ça c'est sûr mais
bon c'était pas une menace
éviter quelque chose qui n'est pas ma
raison
ok il y a trois est-ce qu'il y aura tour
des 7 derrière
pourquoi pas un partage
c'est une grosse bourre parce qu'il y a
pour prendre fou enfin après tout on
prend un tour prend fou vous perdez
votre pion c'est absolument ridicule un
gros E3 tourgers 2 voilà et là il peut
choisir c'est encore fou de sans doute
le bon coup
j'ai tourné cette en plus mais tour
d'essai je vois pas trop trop huit pour
prendre pour prendre
plus peut-être un petit tour j'ai trop
intercalé
bon pourquoi pas
ça me paraît un peu compliqué un peu
même pas jouer ça alors pourquoi on peut
pas jouer ça j'avais envie de jouer 3
[Musique]
c'est pas si bête
parce que bien sûr ouais F2 je prends là
et je prends là je contrôle la case de
promo pro et 2
et là pourquoi c'est si mauvais ce que
le simple roi F6 en fait
et voilà et je perds ça
une fois
donc
donc tourner c'est pas une idée
il faut refaire faux F3 qu'on a vu tout
à l'heure fois 2 qui est logique avec
l'idée tour des 5 FR3 Roy F4 et au sein
dommage j'aurais pu faire avant il a eu
peut-être que redescisse alors juste
tout à l'heure donc il a dû voir ça
Jordana pour G2 ou 2 et C6
comment on passait concrètement parce
que lui c'est sans doute cette position
qu'il a fait douter je sais pas mais je
spécule
en tout cas je peux plus enlever le roi
non mais ça ça fait tellement pas peur
on va le coup on va le croquer hein
on croit que même peut-être ça on croque
tout donc là cet écran tout donc c'est
un peu trompé de Jordan j'ai
l'impression c'est 6 à 5 mais on retombe
si c'est pour éviter ces fils de noir je
comprends pas trop pas du tout ouais
mais je sais pas pourquoi il a joué ça
en fait
est-ce que vous avez trouvé dans le chat
salut le boss Magnus peut gagner oui
il peut gagner mais c'est loin d'être
fait loin d'être fait honnêtement il a
un léger pressing
par contre
c'est Google qui a une position très
intéressante contre un rognium un gros
pressing
et ici
non ça pas été joué j'ai peur
van forest il trouve fou d'eux il a un
gros pressing
on peut jouer
mais c'est un joueur avant de Forrest
donc je vois bien jouer aux deux
et pourra gagner le pion a il peut
perdre gris
peur et que Magnus gagne là c'est Magnus
avec Wesley slow quand même qu'il faut
pas oublier qui pourrait inquiéter un
petit peu mais bon de loin il faut que
Manu gagne
ouais
donc il y a que Magnus et Aniche qui
peuvent faire quelque chose
en cas de nul des deux joueurs Abdou il
va être il va être loin
mais Annie je peux revenir faut surtout
pas caniche perdre sinon c'est
faut au moins soit caniche face nulle
soit que Magnus gagne sinon demain
c'est fini bah ça sera ça sera moins
palpitant normalement parce que devrait
pouvoir assurer nul avec les Blancs il
ne faut pas cadeau puisse assurer une
nul et gagner le tournoi en étant seul
en tête
donc demain le stream est à midi
n'oubliez pas l'horaire un petit peu
décalé pourquoi il y a un horaire décalé
parce qu'en cas de d'égalité il y aura
un match de départage
c'est d'ailleurs cette anecdote des
matchs de départage qui avait été
effectué pendant la partie Dali resa
firuggia qui finissait une finale à les
réservait dit qu'il avait été
déconcentré on lui avait demandé de
quitter son échiquier de se déplacer etc
et après il avait gagé sa finale il
avait dit que c'était un digne d'un
tournoi de très haut niveau de lancer
l'image de partage alors le tournoi
n'était pas fini et on peut être plutôt
d'accord avec lui et
plutôt admis là après lorsque
l'organisation a essayé de le réinviter
au dire de l'organisation comme nous l'a
expliqué Laurent il avait été trop
gourmand dans sa demande financière
apparemment après sera à lui de
s'exprimer là-dessus et c'est la raison
pour laquelle le tournoi
ça va plus se faire il a pas pu rejouer
ce tournoi du tata style pour l'instant
après le temps fera peut-être son effet
et on verra
moi j'aime pas perdre c'est
c'est peut-être une des raisons je peux
pas dire te certifier mais même
l'organisation maintenant est refroidi
lui aussi ils sont en froid en fait tout
simplement donc après il peut ne pas
être disponible pas être motivé il a
peut-être d'autres choses faudrait voir
avec l'intérêt c'est il y a que lui qui
sait
donc tourgé de fou de jouer
là on va
on va avoir
comme un danger dommage qu'il est pas
trouvé tout de suite avec ce pion c'est
alors fouet
maintenant
ouais 4
bon
on va voir
c'est
ah ça y est ça joue côté Carlsen
pragnananda donc on va retourner notre
fil rouge et ça joue vite
dame j'ai un vous l'avez dit c'est
logique que ça joue vite
il a réfléchi bien à son plan pendant un
moment et puis après
après normalement sur mal d'enchaîner
quelques coups et il a trouvé le petit
Prague dame Descartes
mais c'était logique en fait on doit se
créer des pions passés enfin tout donc
Prague il a mangé celui-là pour envoyer
Usain Bolt et pareil nous notre côté
surtout on prend pas on accélère les
pions donc G4
et on arrive quasiment on est quasiment
un point vous voyez
donc c'est beau c'est calculatoire comme
final
il reste quatre coups pour récupérer le
temps donc les 10 minutes vont suffire à
Prague
et maintenant Carlsen doit aussi se
méfier c'est ça le truc
alors un petit peu plus avancé mais j'ai
trois et on aura des échecs aussi et on
contrôle la dame est pas mal placée là
c'est le problème
il faut réfléchir peut-être un petit
échec intermédiaire alors je pense que
va y avoir une réflexion de Magnus je
vous propose quand même qu'on aille voir
goûter ça a beaucoup avancé et là
il y a eu des cours rouges il y a eu des
choses entières j'ai pris un 5 pourquoi
on prend un F5 a été joué
pour un 7 on n'avait pas regarder du
tout pour Google et là il y a eu grosse
bêtise avec
derrière le pion ça fera des échecs et
roi C4 a été joué apparemment il y a
beaucoup d'erreurs vous voyez la genouge
s'exciter
bon déjà toi c'était bizarre c'est pas
ce qu'on avait dit qu'est-ce qu'on avait
dit nous on voulait balancer
final et il y a eu un travail avec tour
à 7 alors tour à 7 c'est peut-être pour
en cas de F6 garder ce pion là très
dangereux
c'est un petit peu c'est fort parce que
du coup pour passer derrière le pion
très avancé le pion g et tout ça
là c'est un petit peu plus compliqué
et du coup c'est là qu'il est G4 tours
G5 et comment on gagne cette position
comment gagner cette position
est-ce qu'on pouvait pas tout simplement
pas tout j'avais envie d'envoyer le pion
à la carte ah c'est un cas si ça c'est
mais
va commencer à s'enjailler ça paraît à
perdant parce que je vais pouvoir
accompagner mon blog de deux pions avec
mon roi
voilà bon je te fais un truc à l'arrache
voilà je croque quand tu arrives proche
de la dame
tu vois que tu accompagnes avec ton roi
PAM et du coup je gagne la finale roi
d'option contre tour
c'est ça ce qu'on a envie de faire
donner la tour contre le pion j'ai gagné
avec deux plombier contre la tour
adverse voilà il faut juste gérer salut
bathy ça fait longtemps j'espère que
tout va bien pour toi
donc du coup dans cette position
ouais franchement
ça paraît maintenant gagnant pour pour
les blancs seuls thématiques à un moment
quand il y aura tout 3 G3 faut pas se
prendre si on se met derrière un échec
et la tour en G4 quoi comme on a dit la
tour derrière le pion mais ici on a la
tour devant notre pion et lui il va se
mettre derrière donc ça nous gêne
avoir Lucas chez-y est-ce que je me mets
directement derrière le pion est-ce que
je commence mes pousser voilà c'était la
réflexion il a commencé ses poussières à
4 et c'est parti c'est parti pour le
show boukh
ça paraît ma langue parquet pour les
voies
alors alors
les vones dans les cordes mais ce qui
nous intéresse le plus c'est guéri
contre vent de Forest il y a eu roi F6
que ça a bougé derrière non toujours pas
il réfléchit est-ce que chez
Magnus ça a bougé non on est dans une
position décisive là B5 G4 donc on reste
sur bookéacha rognon qui peut
potentiellement
avancer un peu plus vite
que tu en penses Fatou est-ce qu'on a le
droit de jouer un coup comme ça
je suis pas sûr qu'on ait le droit
moi je pensais parce que
l'histoire c'est que si
tu me prends
puis on prend et en fait tu es dans le
carré mais c'est un faux amis je fais
Roger 4 et je m'approche
accompagner mon pion
là ça a rien de descendre en D2 j'ai pas
le temps le roi va arriver là donc je
pousse désespérément mon pion
roi G3 surtout la boulette CF2 et la loi
se met là et tant pis on est marron
moi j'ai trois est sur A6 le superweve 2
menace dame ça m'oblige à jouer un coup
droit pour rien et bim tu fais dame sur
échec et tu me bats donc je crois que
les bonnes à rognan il a un seul coup
ici parce qu'il faut que j'envoie ce
pion là j'ai pas de coût utile sinon je
vais me voir l'option A5 tant pis perdu
tout F3 et vous avez vu la jauge elle
aime bien en tout cas
je pousse
aussi mais si je pousse
4 le petit truc pour pouvoir si je
pousse à temps c'est
final
je pense que là de toute façon il n'a
pas le choix les bonnes j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a eu des petits
ratés dans cette finale c'est compliqué
mais il a trouvé tout froid c'est le
seul coup
c'est plus qu'une heure tisé par
personne on a commencé ce stream à 14h
il est 19h30 la cadence si je te la
donne tu vas halluciner parce que c'est
vraiment réservé aux joueurs d'élite les
joueurs de club connaissent un petit peu
c'est les cadences à l'ancienne donc le
tata style pour comparer c'est le
Wimbledon des échecs c'est pas mal dit
donc cadence ça va ancienne
on avait pour les joueurs 1h40 + 30
secondes pour les 40 premiers coups
50 minutes qui te sont rajoutés aux 40e
et toujours 30 secondes par coup et au
60e rajoute encore un quart d'heure donc
tu vois une grosse grosse cadence
tourachette
roi G6 qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire
il veut peut-être simplement venir
bloquer le pion comme ça
et peut-être faire tout rajoute quand
même
mais ça va être sur le fil très
intéressantes j'essaie de surveiller en
même temps les autres échiquier ça joue
pas
c'est un petit peu évolué chez Van
forest bon il va falloir avec les Blancs
soit derrière le pion soit devant
dans l'absolu plutôt derrière mais
attention est-ce qu'il peut pas nous
bloquer
mais en tout cas c'est malin il veut
éviter le
gagnant quand même pour les blancs
en pratique
on prend tous les blancs
entre autre chose ils ont tout à
travailler les joueurs mais ils sont ils
sont très très forts
je suis pas sûr que ça a été
théoriquement nul tout le temps si tu
veux là peut-être maintenant mais il est
clair qu'à un moment ça a tourné
le G4 coup rouge à ce moment là on
devait être gagnant il fallait envoyer
le pion alors ça joue déjà assez vite
pour un chien tout R4
et ça y est c'est perdu
donc vous voyez je voulais dire on va
voir mais
normalement de mettre la tour de manière
assez passive ou devant le pion comme ça
parce que pas accompagner avec le roi ou
le tour pour aller emmener le pur à
dames mais là le fait que les plans ont
deux pions de pion passé qui vont aussi
faire la course à la dame c'est ça qui
veut dire que mettre la tour passive en
G1 c'est
pour arrêter le pion c'est c'est
cohérent
et en fait c'est pas si gagnant que ça
parce qu'il y a tout rêve 5 encore
en fait c'est nul encore parce que la
jauge elle fait des bizarres mais je
comprends en fait là on a des échecs
latéraux pour casser les pieds du roi et
après contrôler les pions et pour les
éviter je suis obligé d'aller en A3 ce
qui est pas terrible c'était pas le plan
donc c'est pas facile encore rien on va
assister à une bonne défense de les voir
à rognon et je pense qu'il a été perdant
ici là
je le savais ouais ouais non mais avec
les ordis c'est toujours un petit peu
différent mais je peux vous dire qu'à le
ruisselle de petits problèmes des deux
côtés d'ailleurs je me demande si les
joueurs n'ont pas été gagnants plus
nulle plus gagnant enfin bref
ok merci
donc il y a pas eu voilà nous on a pas à
l'étable base mais
du coup cette position a été chaude
quand même c'est une défense sur le fil
il était pas sûr les monarrognons mais
ça joue très très bien ça c'est sûr
alors du coup on va juste aller faire un
tout petit tour vers Jordan van forest
pour voir si la réussite il a trouvé le
setup d'attaque
avec le rond F4 il savait de toute façon
A4
il a juste fait 6 pour rien elle a perdu
un temps en fait ton G8
avec des idées E5 évidemment
[Musique]
tourgé 6 échec et on a le roi bah voilà
qui est obligé de garder de ne pas
garder justement la protection sur la
tour la problématique qu'on a c'est
maintenant ce pion est dangereux quand
même Laurie à chaque fois il faut
regarder normalement il aurait été là si
il y avait pas eu ce petit C6
peut-être pas le meilleur mais je vais
vite le premier coup qui me passait par
la tête en U7 ah oui oui d'accord oui il
y a une explication c'est que dans cette
position sur roi prend 5 je peux faire à
deux si j'étais en F7 il y avait des 5
échecs et mon pion était perdu là je
vais la dame donc on regrette avec
Jordan sans doute d'avoir poussé
d'avoir poussé le
pousser le fiancé 6 qui a aidé les Noirs
à pousser ce plan-là qui est très
dangereux ça va faire
pour éviter que le roi soit bien placé
et là il vient chercher le pion à
on doit se méfier à deux jouets
c'est encore gagnant c'est encore
gagnant alors
on gagnons que je sais pas mais en tout
cas il y a encore un thème E5 c'est vrai
que c'est dangereux ma tour contrôle
qu'est-ce qu'il veut jouer alors
jusqu'à deux ça a l'air d'être le coup
on devait faire tourcer trois
est-ce que c'est tour C3 avec une idée
dingue
c'est compliqué toutes les finales qu'on
a
extrêmement forts et on voit qu'elles
sont extrêmement compliquées les finales
ça c'est clair sur ces trois j'ai pas
ton idée de dingue est-ce qu'on pourrait
sacrifier et reprendre le pion pour
jouer la finale de tour
[Musique]
je pense que la jauge joue des tours E5
normal voilà la jauge n'arrête pas de
faire des zéros à donc on va pas déjà
que j'aime pas la jauge et en fait on
reste la regarder bêtement
et je vois qu'il y en a qui
regarde l'ordi en tout cas on doit
mettre la jauge
c'est pas clair mais en fait vous
regardez beaucoup les ordis savoir mais
il faut faire attention quand même bon
après vous faites comme vous voulez
du coup en pratique cette position est
plus facile à jouer pour pour vendre
forest
parce que vous voyez bien l'idée on en
avait parlé dès le départ en fait si
j'arrive à mettre mes deux comptes
le roi va commencer à avoir du mal
il y a grosse menace là alors comment on
fait
encore mais ça va être joué par 5 j'ai
pas trop de coups
et c'est d'ailleurs jouer à l'instant
je vois un instant
et puis la tour
à vide qui a un rôle défensif et où
partir
avec avec les noirs
pour 8 meilleures coups et oui on avait
oublié ce petit coup mais c'est très
très bien joué comme ça ça laisse des
places pour le roi sur la 8e rangée
grâce aux pions à 2
j'aurais bien aimé voir cette même
partie sans le coup c'est 6
nous on n'avait pas prévu ça au départ
de Cécile on revient on revient au
moment où c'est si ça a été joué s'il
avait joué toute la même partie je vais
faire juste pour voir
ok on va partir sur le même principe de
A5
est-ce que je pouvais jouer
F3 pas nécessairement en fait
c'était compliqué en fait c'était pas
pas gagnant non plus fou F3C au noir de
jouer
toutes ces deux ça paraît normal tour
des 5
alors que c'est génial ma tour mais
rester dans la main c'est incroyable roi
F6
ça me fait un truc hyper bizarre c'est
génial ouais ouais
4 il y avait un harcèlement par derrière
sans doute carnet du guerrier avait
prévu cette défense là
très joli on peut en parler parce que
toi F2 c'était aussi un motif défensif
sur E5 sacrifice de tour
de prise tout reprend F3 ok d'accord bon
on voit que c'est pas facile du tout
progresser et c'est pour ça qu'il a
essayé sans doute avec des différentes
subtilités et on va arriver quand même
sur une sorte de match nul
à deux E5 tours 8
ça pose des problèmes mais ça joue
extrêmement bien des deux côtés un même
après plus de 5h30 ça joue très très
bien
partout
ma fille va bien oui est-ce que c'est
une future championne d'échec elle
connaît les règles depuis toute petite
mais je t'avoue que ben je l'ai pas mis
au jeu d'échec parce qu'elle fait un peu
ce qu'elle veut là elle fait de la gym
alors je suis pas un grand gymnaste donc
mais bon elle est petite et j'ai pas
enfin j'ai vu plusieurs mauvaises
exemples en fait en tant que coach
entraîneur donc j'ai plutôt le postulat
de dire aux enfants bah en fait ce que
vous aimez faites ce que vous voulez
surtout à cet âge là et encore plus
après voilà il vit on peut faire
découvrir c'est ce que j'ai voulu faire
parce que ma passion ses échecs où j'ai
voulu apprendre tout à ma fille à
déplacer les pièces mais elle a pas
encore à 7 ans la fibre donc moi je
laisse si elle veut jouer je suis
d'accord et sinon on reste on reste
comme ça pour l'instant il y a pas il y
a pas besoin quoi enfin il y a pas
besoin alors c'est une belle vision des
choses
je pense que c'est normal on a vu des
exemples tellement nuls entre guillemets
à ce niveau là que c'est bien de j'ai vu
dans certains
hyper sympa de venir très bête il y a
pas d'autres mots
par rapport à l'aspect compétition
en en demandant trop à leur enfant en
étant orienté par le résultat
sous prétexte que les parents étaient
investis soit par rapport à leur temps
qu'il consacrera la discipline soit par
rapport à l'argent qu'il consacrer à la
discipline et je pense que c'est pas
seulement dans le monde des échecs c'est
dans le monde du sport en général dans
le monde de la compétition
mais il faut faire attention de pas de
pas cramer entre guillemets de pas
finalement
être plus
gênant pour son enfant qui est dans
voilà on est là pour aider
on est là pour donner le goût de
l'effort je pense en tant que coach en
tant que parents mais il faut pas que ça
devienne du grand n'importe quoi et que
la discipline qu'on émet devienne une
hyper contrainte sous prétexte que il y
a un investissement des parents du coup
il y aura des résultats c'est pas comme
ça que ça marche quand on fait une
compète il y a deux joueurs il y a deux
équipes et tout le monde veut gagner
voilà donc c'est dur et finalement ceux
qui font le plus d'efforts sur le long
terme qui sont récompensés
mais c'est dur c'est dur en fait ce qui
prennent du plaisir parce que il y en a
qui finissent par être d'écouter
qui sentent forcer quoi de jouer au
final et ils veulent plus jouer pour par
peur de perdre et du coup de pas
et
au niveau français
on a pas tant que ça de grand maître
mais on a de grands maîtres d'extrême
qualité et je me demande si c'est pas
parce que justement en règle générale
l'école française ça reste quand même
une école du plaisir on ne force pas les
jeunes à travailler et tôt on va dire
qu'on forcer ça dépend des philosophies
etc mais en tout cas dans certaines
nations et âpre dur nous on a des grands
maîtres qui peuvent jouer longtemps et
du coup qui maximise leur potentiel si
tout vient de même cette envie de
travailler ben forcément ils vont aller
beaucoup plus loin que déjà qu'on aurait
un peu poussé justement je pense voilà
donc
je remarque qu'on a peu de grand maître
mais ils sont extrêmement forts à un
moment on était dans les 10 meilleurs
nations mondiales en termes de moyenne
élo à 5 joueurs bon avec l'arrivée d'Ali
resa à pyrugia qui a pas été formé en
France ça biaise un peu les choses mais
pour le coup si on fait la moyenne
Moussard Bacro
mvl
Maxime Lagarde Laurent Freyssinet
Christian Bauer on n'est pas mal on est
pas mal Matthieu cornette Sébastien
Mazet c'est très fort aussi mais bon
j'ai pris j'ai pris les meilleurs
du coup on se défend bien à l'échelle
même mondiale Laurie texte qu'est-ce qui
explique cela alors qu'on a on n'a pas
50 grands mètres en France quoi on est
aussi on a on a eu peut-être 552 je sais
plus puisque Maurice c'est 50e grand
maître français bon bref on en a pas
tant que ça mais ils sont globalement
très très fort
j'aime beaucoup Yannick il y a pas mais
je pensais au hello j'ai fait quasiment
l'ordre et l'eau de tête et Yannick qui
est un peu en deçà à moi qui l'ai
regagné des points mais là j'ai cité des
joueurs à plus à plus de 2600
je suis pas capable aller chez le
Mondial de dire donc en France je dirais
80 licenciés après il y a licence a
licence B il faudrait que j'aille sur le
site de la fédé oui romain Édouard Cyril
en fait romain Édouard c'est pareil je
l'ai joué alors il y a une petite
anecdote comme ça Cyril c'est plutôt
marrant d'ailleurs c'est contre moi mais
c'est marrant
romain Édouard a atteint une fois les
2700 enfin la première fois et c'était
en battant il lui fallait un point hello
je me suis retrouvé très bien après
l'ouverture après c'était encore égal
j'ai fait j'ai fini par lui faire une
livraison et je lui ai offert ces 2700
points
durement acquis par ailleurs mais après
ça a été un peu la descente aux enfers
en termes de points hello pour Romain
j'espère pour lui qui va revenir voilà
mais là il a un petit hello à peu près
25 90 je dirais ce qui est faible pour
pour le niveau qu'il avait réussi à
atteindre un moment il gagnait tout
quand il est passé 2700 il a gagné
beaucoup d'Open dans cette période là
mais en tout cas il y a énormément les
inciter dans notre chat voilà énormément
de joueurs français très très forts pour
peu de grand maître en proportion si
vous voulez
voilà du coup qu'est-ce qui se passe
chez Carlsen ça a beaucoup évolué on est
obligé d'aller voir il y a eu que trois
coups mais la position elle a une tête
tête bizarre B prend un 6 il a piqué du
pion quand il dit de toute façon
j'aurais su faire une autre dame après
j'ai trois à 7 on y va dans ma huit on
bloque le petit pion et roi des 6 c'est
rigolo roi des 6 hein on laisse une
fausse enfilade
parce que finalement je pourrais aller
n'importe où avec mon roi je peux faire
dames mais je peux aussi revenir vers
les pions Magnus il s'amuse
maintenant les chances de gains
paraissent limitées mais il va essayer
j'ai deux d'imbé 6 et on se prend pas le
coup d'échec ici en jouant Roger 7 bon
je sais pas trop je pense que ça va
faire nul
mais il essaye il essaye et c'est tout à
son honneur on voit des belles valeurs
dans au niveau de cette élite mondial
ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'avant on
reprochait aux joueurs des nulle rapide
des nuls insipides il y en a pas
beaucoup dans ce tournoi franchement
c'est assez exceptionnel les joueurs
quand ils font nuls c'est des grosses
finales et épousent tout on a quand même
deux résultats décisifs actuellement et
de nul il y a que ceux qui a été modeste
mais car Wana il a vraiment essayé de
jouer à Blue ça t'auras bah il avait les
Noirs il peut pas faire grand chose face
à un saut qui décide de jouer de manière
très voire trop posée c'est un peu
dommage
en plus il y avait une remarque de
Laurent par rapport à ça qui disait
wesleo il est génial mais il prend pas
assez de risques et tu as vu dans
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment décevant et
quelqu'un nous l'a dit dans le chat
aussi tout à l'heure j'ai pas retenu le
pseudo mais en tout cas il nous disait
trop gentil ne m'en dis pas mais ok
c'est un compétiteur il doit jouer pour
gagner
c'est ouais ouais j'ai mal où on est
d'accord
ah selon les jours les joueurs ça peut
s'expliquer mais ouais
franchement ça me dérange pas mais je
trouve que dans l'ensemble ça a beaucoup
joué mais Wesley joue pour le gain du
tournoi qu'on a boussole blanc et il
fait une partie il échange les dames et
il fait et pose aucun problème
bizarre c'est un peu décevant ça j'aime
bien le combat
c'est un super jour d'échec
Ino bat à la vague pas de souci et
pourquoi il va pas jouer et prendre les
risques c'est ce qu'on aime on voit au
tennis la mentalité des grands champions
Djoko Nadal Federer pour une citer que
ben là quand ça nous montre cette
attitude là
et dirige ou toutes ces parties aussi en
ce moment ça pas toujours été le cas non
mais il faut jouer quoi faut jouer
Douda c'est bien aussi enfin bref
normalement c'est des joueurs qui qui
vont au bout des choses en tout cas
numéro un mondial très dominant Magnus
il joue quasiment tout à fond voilà il
veut coller au joueur en fait qui est
nul ça me dérange pas parce que
Eva des fois ces jours je veux
parfaitement ils font nuls c'est le haut
niveau ça ça me dérange pas mais je veux
que ce soit des nuls de combat
et là c'est le cas là
des fois elle est partie deviennent
plates etc comme nous dit Eva et puis
c'est on préfère les résultats décisifs
mais deux résultats décisifs et trois
parties qui jouent tard c'est bien quoi
c'est bien
du coup je ne ferai si il pose les
problèmes il a trouvé aussi encore
c'est chiant franchement attention
attention Guy du roi
si le roi commence à rentrer on peut
avoir des motifs et c'est pour ça que
parfois la guêpe Aniche tu l'as bien
compris ça il a dit non dans ton roi il
reste là il reste avec moi des copains
et après il faut retrouver des
mécanismes pour essayer de filouter un
petit peu genre je fais 3 je fais x 4 et
après je remonte au lit par là haut par
là et j'essaye un truc de passer avec
mon roi le roi passé
mais là sera le roi passé
et puis on fait maintenant après bon je
sais pas comment encore alors il met je
vais essayer de faire un truc quoi après
je vais m'en fous en dessin qu'à un
moment je cravate à deux et après j'y
vais quoi mais bon ça c'est les rêves
c'est pour ça que je peux pas faire
n'importe quoi sinon j'aimerais bien
faire
6 bouffe et des guilis mais ça va être
dur pour E5 fois 4 F6 aussi ça peut être
comme ça
c'est vrai free bird c'est pour ça que
j'essaye un truc comme ça peut-être on
verra c'est pour l'instant je peux pas
donc je vais être obligé de passer par
là monter le fou c'est très mécanique
mais bon on guérit il peut pas faire
grand-chose c'est une bonne position
pour vous l'été par contre les joueurs
regardent moins 15 minutes encore le riz
quoi je pense
quand il tombe en fait ça dépend
maintenant c'est un nouvel règle et
pendule rajoute quand on tombe faut
juste savoir bien contrôler le temps ça
c'est stress
tout le temps quoi alors
Magnus ça joue plus
le roi des 6
mais Prague il a plus que deux couches
ça va il va s'en sortir
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on va
regarder
on était arrêté à chaque fois
et on va voir qu'il y a eu un gros coup
rouge
on va voir est-ce que c'est un vrai koku
donc
tout F4
la pendule 15 minutes on est cool en
plus de 60 amères atteint regardez tout
reste 5 rois BK
il est allé il veut gagner
il va se cacher un peu comme tu as dit
j'ai trois tours
là c'est la logique de jouer tout
refroidir
ok ok
j'ai envie de faire
je préférais pousser sur mon pion plus
avancé honnêtement honnêtement je le dis
hein bah oui c'était pas le bon coup
mais ça donnait envie à 5 je le fais
comme boukes
qu'est-ce qu'il fallait jouer là
BK
parce que peut-être que mon ouais donc
c'est le pion bec il faut pousser
c'était bien ça B4 ah non c'est pas bien
non plus ah peut-être ah tu vois c'est
dur
voilà on y comprend ouais les cours
rouges on va les bannir c'était bécasse
proposait plus de problèmes
c'est incompréhensible c'est plus
logique de pousser le champ éloigné si
vous voulez pour moi B5 gros e 6 B6
et je me faisais coupé à la fin
et qu'est-ce que ça va changer avec at
ah ouais le pion a en fait
l'option 1 c'est peut-être que quand la
tour va venir il y aura un échec
ah c'est horrible à 5 rois F7 et genre
sur A6 il y a toujours G6
donc j'ai poussé le pion à pour rien
donc du coup je suis obligé de
l'accompagner par B4
le roi raboule
à 6
roi des 7 à 7 la tour G8 ça fait nul ah
oui parce que je peux pas bouffer ça
donc est-ce que B4 donc gagner ou non
c'est pas sûr quand même sur ce coup
rouge je sais pas l'impression moi dès
que on va voir est-ce que je peux pas je
peux pareil ça gagne
au revoir
[Rires]
qui nous dit je ne comprends rien à
cette finale mais globalement ça me
ferait bien plaisir que à rognon perdre
parce qu'il n'a pas été très combatif et
ben je crois que B4 gagnait peut-être
alors on va refaire roi F7 B5 le pion
est très pénible à arrêter
punaises
pour G8 pour faire la même
et là j'ai tout B un incroyable
G2 et maintenant je vais la réalité de
deux petits pions à 5
pas sûr
c'est même pas sûr que ça gagne en fait
non c'est pas sûr
A5 Carroi c'est 6 encore à 6 non mais
c'était vraiment les finales c'est hyper
dur vous voyez on était à deux doigts
cette position n'est pas sûr du tout bon
arrêtez
très très chaud parce que dès que je
joue à 7
par exemple joue tout F8 imaginons dès
que je dois non mais c'est trop
compliqué trop compliqué enfin on voit
pour le module c'est compliqué alors
pour les joueurs c'est compliqué et je
joue très bien
mais bon
BK
je t'assure c'est très très dur donc va
peut-être nous mettre tout à l'heure il
nous a mis B4 pourquoi F5
je voulais pas jouer bon c'est pas grave
B6 bon roi des 5 on retombe dans
celle-là
un roi des cinq c'était tout simple
mais sur roi des 7 tours aussi de toute
façon ok
tout à l'heure ça nous a été proposé et
tout G7
pour G7 j'ai peut-être tours C7
pas sûr parce que je laisse passer non
mais bon ok tour G7 je fais à 5
G2 à 6
j'ai 2
je fais gaffe quand même parce que j'ai
pas envie que
ça a l'air douille
ouais ça a l'air bon j'ai regardé quand
même géant parce que j'avais peur que tu
me chopes
[Musique]
avec G5 tours passe derrière et que je
me fasse choper les pions tours c'est
donc il y avait une coupe mais il y a
une coupe mais c'était dur à trouver bah
d'ailleurs vous voyez comme c'est dur le
joueur à 2007 honnêtement vous avez
cette position
voilà c'est très très fort un des
meilleurs espoirs au monde et encore
espoir espoir confirmé qu'on ait plus de
7 maintenant un jour pour le titre
mondial c'est tout mal qu'on lui
souhaite mais vraiment vous espions là
vous avez envie de pousser à 5 de toute
façon vous dites je pourrais bouger mon
roi en fait c'est B4 ce qu'il faut
pousser parce qu'on soutient les deux
alors qu'il y a plein d'histoires
d'échecs dans dans l'histoire de de
jouer le pion assez c'est très très dur
très très dur il a pas trouvé en partie
lente nous on l'aurait pas trouvé à
tempo couper le roi en sait faire mais
se retenir de jouer à 4 c'est très très
dur
trop naturel et maintenant il voit que
c'est nul je pense à 5 bref 7 B4 ça va
annuler
très très chaud alors
Carlsen pragnanda ça a bougé de partout
le riz quelques coups de jouer j'ai deux
trois cinq il ramène son roi dame F3
Dame des 8 échec
bon
on va repartir pour un tour je vois
l'histoire de carlossen il a fait dames
mais il est plus proche
je peux faire dames à n'importe quel
moment je peux aussi faire quelques
échecs si je veux pour améliorer et
garder de dames non mais c'est surtout
parce qu'il faut faire parce que là je
vais me prendre des trucs avec des deux
dames de Magnus
ouais je vais changer je pense que c'est
le plus simple non il y a pas eu de
défaite au temps si c'est ça la question
c'est qui tombe et elle a la période
suivante période de temps donc au 40e
coupure au 60e là où ils reprennent le
temps mais le temps arrive quand il
tombe exactement
il a récupéré son quart d'heure le
dernier quart d'heure de Prague
ce qui est super salut j'aime pas perdre
que je propose une j'aime pas perdre je
sais plus qui est venu mais c'est bien
vous êtes très nombreux on a une belle
fin belle fin de stream parce que
souvent on a qu'une partie à commenter
là on peut on peut passer sur trois
parties
avec tout son gokash avec tout son temps
il rate bah c'est chaud pour pour nous
on vous l'assure mais c'est ça en vibre
au moins et du coup il a choisi il a
choisi le petit Prague il a pas choisi
d'échanger les dames il a fait son petit
chèque
c'est pas bête aussi il préfère deux
dames sur l'échiquier pour faire des
perpettes
parce qu'il va contrôler regarde c'est
mignon remarque
où je vais avec mon roi
un bordel on va avoir une finale avec
deux dames c'est très très rare d'avoir
de dames chacun bien sûr et final de
dames sont très fréquentes mais deux
dames chacun c'est rare
et c'est vrai qu'en mettant ma dame en
C3
je peux contrôler la case huit d'échec
et en faisant d'âme je contrôle la case
G8 il y aura encore
est-ce que je peux jouer dame décape
pour contrôler ah oui mesdames échangent
on apprend échec malin et oui malin
Prague
c'est beau
dans ces trois très joli coup il y a
plusieurs façons de faire nul mais c'est
plus précis car le scène propose des
problèmes lui il essaie de bien répondre
en dégoutant un peu caresser en lui
disant c'est bon ta boîte le numéro 1
mondial je défends ça tous les jours on
arrête quoi et du coup il essaie
d'être le plus précis
le Magnus il doit tout vérifier
maintenant il faut pas qu'il fasse
n'importe quoi il va est-ce qu'il va
aller en D6 peut-être est-ce qu'on peut
se cacher là ouais mais c'est bizarre
donc est-ce qu'on ferait je peux
rajouter des échecs si je veux donc on
va
là
Dame des 4 jouets Dame des cartes de
Magnus il veut échanger les dames tant
pis pour les chèques
bon il a dit peut-être j'en ai marre là
non
parce que maintenant il pourra se casser
quelque part sur les cimetière anus
change d'échec
se cacher c'est pas sûr je vois pas où
il se cache
il fait
pas se cacher normalement
sur un
je vois pas comment il se cache un
oreille parce que si tu te mets à 7
proche de la dame je fais les chèques
ici ici et chaque ici et chaque et tu te
caches pas donc ils vont jouer
mais maintenant il va y avoir une
perpète un peu bête je pense
genre ça et
parce que Manu c'est dangereux qu'on
peut pas commencer à jouer
à moins que Magnus se mette en 4 et qui
se prennent en finale mais je crois pas
bizarrement pas qu'il se prenne
l'enfilade Magnus aujourd'hui
avec avec 40 minutes autant je crois pas
ce serait
salut Gilles et oui oui ça va être
complètement nul
je pensais qu'on allait avoir la fenêtre
avec deux dames
ça aurait pu
il y a un pion de moins mais ce qu'on
avait dit c'est que le pion passé le
plus avancé c'est celui-là qui compte
donc les blancs sont presque un peu
mieux c'est les noirs qui font perdre
ici
crack va pas jouer à 5 qui va arriver en
retard voilà on va arriver là on sera de
bouger la dame bon il y a pas trop
d'intérêt pour les deux joueurs je pense
pas je pense que Magnus il a l'air
d'être un peu blasé il est en arrière
sur son siège je pense qu'ils vont faire
nulle dans pas longtemps très grave
vérifier
il serait capable de jouer roi E3 pour
pas jouer xcood plus voilà bah c'est
d'ailleurs il vient de le faire voilà
donc je pense que ça va répéter comme ça
une petite réputation pour jouer 50
coups dans cette position ça a été le
serrage demain je pense qu'on va voir ça
en direct
et grosse grosse partie des deux joueurs
en fait elle était monstrueuse cette
partie dommage pour Manu je pense que ça
lui a coûté cher il a fait une toute
petite erreur non mais c'est des
Orfèvres franchement
vous rappelez de ce moment où en fait
Magnus le moment où il a peut-être fait
sa plus grosse erreur de la partie c'est
le moment il a pris le pion d'avance et
PRAG a réussi à trouver l'initiative il
avait deux manières de le prendre et une
après coup qui semblait laissez-moi
l'initiative à l'adversaire c'est parce
que Manu ça jugé partie énorme et Prague
va être content avec les Noirs sortir
une partie comme ça c'est monstrueux
d'ailleurs parce que quand même hier
c'était décevant il avait vraiment il
était passé avec les Blancs complètement
à côté et c'est dur le lendemain vous
jouez 45 avec les noirs
et là il est fort très fort
comme des enfants là la petite nul
le
bravo
c'est bon c'est beau c'est beau de faire
nul noir Carl Seine dans une partie de
combat et il a le sourire Prague c'est
pas rien pour un petit bonhomme comme ça
il peut être fier bravo
c'est bien il me propose de du Beaujeu
c'est Laurent qui nous dit ça content de
discuter avec la nouvelle génération
Magnus c'est bien
il est tellement dominant voilà et kiffe
regardez c'est un ultra compétiteur et
c'est pas le Magnus qui se cache il a
fait nul blanc Prague c'est pas une
perte mais l'estime qu'il a bien joué il
avait d'échanger avec son jeune
adversaire qui a pas fait une partie
dégueu
rare c'est pas ça mais de manière aussi
détendu
c'est un ultra compétiteur franchement
tu es champion du monde c'est ultra
dominant mais il a envie de faire des
échecs il a envie d'analyser les parties
en fait
le tournoi il a fait ça à chaque fois
parce que on voyait discuter avec ses
adversaires très détendu et même quand
il s'est fait bâcher
ok ça ça arrive par contre il revient le
gamin les parties bon ça s'enflamme à
chaque fois un petit peu quand on voit
Magnus perd une partie alors comme il en
a perdu deux et que c'est à peu près
deux parties qui perd l'année voire
moins
ça s'est enflammé en fait il a remis des
pendules à l'heure en terme de qualité
de jeu par contre Magnus risque d'être
loin maintenant en termes de classement
il y a un point d'abusiness au Rohff il
n'y a plus qu'à espérer que Guerin ne
perd pas cette position
et ça avance pas beaucoup l'histoire de
Jordan forest mais il y a le pressing il
y a le pressing
je sais pas comment il va faire pour
avancer
alors
est-ce qu'on est on est à niveau ici le
roi est revenu
et en fait cette position elle est nulle
parce que le pion A7 est trop avancé
donc il est désuni depuis
c'est terrible
mais dans cette position
roi piontour c'est nulle espion là ça
sert à rien je vais me prendre plein
d'échecs je peux pas je peux pas
vraiment améliorer cette pause
il y a un peu de travail encore
j'ai envie de jouer de tour C8 pour
couper le roi
mais en même temps hop après tout Rachel
je fais comment
et encore un peu de boulot pour les
vannes
si je fais plein d'échecs avec ma tour
le Roi peut monter mais ça fera pas
grand chose non plus
je peux faire plein d'échecs avec ma
tour en fait et revenir sur la case
initiale
moi je vais cet homme de défense le riz
je crois que c'est pas hyper dur de
faire nulle avec les Noirs c'est normal
que les voix rognons elles sont en mais
on voit la tête de bouquet il se rend
bien compte
voilà il commence une série d'échecs
sans doute ininterrompue
le Roi peut plus avancer quoi si je me
mets là avec le roi bah je reviens avec
ma toux
et après je peux aller à 8 pour prendre
le bouton une fois que le roi et dans
cette zone là je peux jouer la finale de
pion évidemment
donc c'est à dire que je peux pas le
prendre pour l'instant Laurie le pion
sinon j'ai perdre la finale le roi blanc
va passer devant le pion dans de bonnes
conditions
comme ça ton roi il va il va aller loin
du jeu hop il va se mettre là par
exemple et là à ce moment là faudrait
peut-être plus envie d'aller croquer le
pion voilà
on va voir mais il y aura pas mal
d'échecs vraisemblablement
pour les joueurs on se rend pas compte
c'est de joueurs qui sont géniaux ok
mais
en fait une partie comme ça ils y sont
depuis deux heures il est 8h tu vois 6
heures dans la tronche de partie d'échec
pour dominer les voies à rognan et pas
le finir
tu as les yeux comme ça la fin il aurait
gagné il aurait les smileys il aura
encore les nerfs mais là ça retombe ça
retombe en fait ça retombe c'est dur dur
d'assurer
exactement exactement ça
du coup ça c'est ok on va retourner voir
ici cette position qui n'avance pas
beaucoup bref qu'à Toure F2 3 on est
passé en G3 là il part par E3
et un moment faudra qu'il se décide pour
y aller
il fait tourner un c'est un peu des
positions c'est dans la lessiveuse si tu
veux Laurie le fameux tourner pour
gagner une belle image
c'est c'est le truc classique j'en ai
perdu pas mal contre des grands mattes
qui ont commencé à me tourner tu es
fatigué tu as 6 heures dans les jambes
et là là c'est des joueurs de très haut
niveau
mais je sais qu'il y a des grands
maîtres qui m'ont fait du mal à me
tourner des positions qui sont nulles
mais c'est eux qui jouent pour le gain
et ils te font du mal ils font du mal je
me rappelle en 2011
c'est Vacher la graves qui m'avait fait
ça c'était archi nul et un moment
mauvais coup droit patatra BIM défaite
en un coup et c'est oui c'est ça le jeu
c'est c'est vraiment c'est vraiment très
très donc c'est Jordan qui peut gagner
il contrôle le pion il y a pas de risque
et il sait qu'à un moment s'il arrive à
passer le roi s'il arrive à pousser ses
pions la config peut être gagnante il
faut qu'il arrive à faire F6
oui c'est le temps le manque de temps
qui peut qui peut créer plus facilement
ils ont pas eu encore leur rajoute par
contre il leur reste 15 minutes de
réserve
ce centième il fait vraiment mal le
reste de la cadence j'aime bien
mais le petit quart d'heure en plus il
fait mal et à Nice il va s'en servir
clairement
il faut que j'essaie de trouver le setup
me permettant de pousser
je vais jouer ça
ça avance pas beaucoup l'histoire
elle joue tout à 8 un tour à 8 parce
qu'il menace vraiment le pion
il va croquer le pion
ou pas ou pas parce que si on croit que
le pion on perd la partie avec avec j'ai
cru qu'il avait une idée pas du tout
si je craque le pion roi à 5 oppositions
je suis devant mon pion j'ai
l'opposition il peut pas prendre
en fait j'ai une petite
[Rires]
voilà non bon là c'est juste que
je continuera pas longtemps ça me paraît
vraiment pour le coup facile
donc il n'y a plus qu'une partie
on a eu des beaux combats mais des beaux
combats qui sont terminés par la nul
voilà il va tout à fait
pour moi
pour B2 jouer par
un niche qui peut se balader sur la
deuxième en fait il peut faire ce qu'il
veut et comment nous on essaie de
progresser petit à petit lapin à pas
comment on le fait d'où cette main
ce que je dois me cacher des échecs
et la tour à mon pourrait aller en D8
aussi il y aurait 6 donc je vais faire
allez
au 4
parce que si je fais roi F4 on commence
à la connaître celle-là on sait ce qui
se passe allez
4 et puis arrêter de me prendre la
thématique pénible un petit peu
et je peux passer par là ou là je pense
passer par là
ça
ce qui est pénible c'est que quand
j'arrive là pour faire F6 les noirs
peuvent peut-être faire tourner 5
et sur foulard peut-être tourner 8
faudra regarder mais la
tournée mais bon ok c'est moi qui joue
je peux faire le test en fait ce qui est
bien dans ces lessiveuses dans ses
positions tournées pour gagner c'est
qu'il n'y a que moi qui joue pour le
gain donc j'ai le droit de faire des
tests l'adversaire est un peu paralysé
en dépense comme tu le vois Lorie donc
je fais des tests en bougeant les pièces
on peut et pour fatiguer la défense
et après je reviens en arrière comme à
essayer de le faire bouquet sauf qu'il y
avait plus rien à faire
donc
sans dégrader sa position tant mieux on
essaye on y va et pas de vous les faire
fouder 5 attends après pour B25 mais
[Musique]
je m'étais dit qu'on pouvait jouer pour
des 8 mais peut-être qu'on prend un deux
des cinq intéressants pas de métal
c'est pas ce qui a été joué
menacé F6
j'aime bien ton couple
voici la page où il y a quand même une
raison donc
qu'est-ce qu'il a vu
des cinq est-ce que j'avais le droit de
jouer roi 7 pas de métal un peu délirant
recette mais pourquoi pas
ah non non je peux pas si peut-être
c'était je peux je peux venir comme ça
c'est pas si bête
très compliqué en tout cas
c'est bizarre
ça paraît risqué quand même une histoire
et surtout prends c'est ça que j'avais
prévu roi des 6 tours
E5 peut-être après vous êtes sacrifié
votre fou on a deux comment je défends
alors on va voir c'est bien roi et le
coin ça
j'ai vérifié mais les rois des six et
tour des sets on peut même la paumer
avec 5 à peindre
je pensais que ça c'était chaud j'ai
peur faut prendre un deux pour prendre
un deux je vais aller cette position je
savais pas trop comment la juger
apparemment ça va pour les Noirs mais
vous voyez il y a beaucoup de pions donc
c'est toujours dans dangereux surtout
après quelques heures de commentaires on
a peur de de se tromper là et les
joueurs ben ils ont peur de se tromper
aussi donc on a des cartes de toute
façon je peux faire les tests avec
Jordan peut faire des tests
elle est dure quand même position pour
pour Aniche doit tout surveiller avec le
temps il va pas avoir on va ça va durer
ça va durer je vous le dis parce que
à une Jordan normalement la technique
dans ses positions là vous essayez un
petit peu tout et vous attendez que le
mec soit en zeinte et même à niche qui
peut jouer très vite on les a vu au
speech à Nice s'il a envie je joue très
vite c'est un genre très sérieux mais il
peut jouer très vite
il faut faire gaffe quoi il faut faire
gaffe
ça fait longtemps que vous êtes en train
de défendre votre pause faut pas
déconner
je pense qu'il comprend très bien la
position mais il est sous pression une
bêtise est vite arrivé Lorie dans ce
genre de
temps le temps fait les choses donc
quand c'est nul le plat OK
mais
bon là on est dans une config
et je reviendrai en A7 c'est chaud on va
regarder
le roi autre part quand F6 là je suis
obligé de retourner une extrémiste parce
que sinon il y a des tours à 8 ou à un
DAB déjà et la tour D8 le contre je
re cinq on voit que je prends beaucoup
d'échecs latéraux ça me dit pas donc je
vais aller en C5
je me prends pour C2 ok je me bats je
vais enlever 6
c'est nul ça c'est chaud
quand même c'est un argument
F6 c'est 7 il y a quand même
cacher
5 ah oui mais si je me casse maintenant
regardez un truc bien quoi si je me
casse roi c'est 5 tours c'est deux et
maintenant il y a menace de Tours
français 7 c'est super chaud mais il a
trouvé il a trouvé alors il avait pas
beaucoup de choix en fait dans cette
position
on voyait la config arriver fou des
seins gros E5 un comment on en parlait
tout à l'heure il a pas voulu la jouer
au roi G7
je pense qu'il aurait dû être un peu
plus patient il a trop montré ses
intentions Jordan mais bon ok c'est un
super joueur c'est pas facile de tout
voir ils sont fatigués et Aniche défend
très bien
il doit trouver à des coûts pour poser
des problèmes Jordan c'est pas facile
donc rose 5 ça se doit pas être possible
tomber 5 faut des 5 c'est la grosse
gaffe on a parlé pour D8
il a pas ce coup-là pas de bol pas de
bol c'est pas normal non plus hein et tu
ressens actives
on a vu juste ça en pratique c'est ce
qui a l'air d'être le plus
le plus dangereux
ça je te mets en roi là je repars là bas
et maintenant ben j'ai un pion passé de
plus j'ai trois pions passés
[Musique]
je peux pas essayer un truc comme ça
c'est un coup on peut perdre aussi avec
les Blancs un monde d'inattention bon
normalement il y a pas de raison mais
c'est dur c'est dur
ou 4 et on joue aux échecs on voit il va
essayer ça leur donne je pense c'est
logique de jouer ça
on va voir mais pour moi il va essayer
de pousser pousser pousser
voilà c'est le moment du calcul du plan
pas juste d'un coup mais vraiment du
plan donc c'est pour ça qu'ils a
sûrement prendre plus de temps
c'est LA grande décision mais oui ça se
peut régler blanc Mitsou en essayant en
plus
c'est ça qui est terrible mais l'effort
grand maître les joueurs expérimentés
ils continuent ces positions il y a
évidemment une méfiance à avoir mais pas
de peur
il faut se battre de toute façon il faut
poser les problèmes ça joue très très
bien franchement
la partie elle est énorme aussi il y a
vraiment pas eu beaucoup de bêtises
Peppa il a failli passer dessus
on peut on peut juste regretter que
Jordan est pas trouvé et les coups qui
font mal
ça aurait pu être une partie bâchée en
quelques coups avec l'attaque gagnante
le rythme c'était très difficile de
trouver il en était compliqué aussi mais
il a failli faire une partie mais juste
génialissime tu fais la prépa et après
tu joues tous les coups
et tu trouves une conception de malade
avec le roi H2 comme on avait vu tout ça
c'était très très joli
alors rappelle le début de partie avec
le la petite qualité qui s'en va
préparer
c'était beau c'était la partie la plus
impressionnante
donc oui c'est impressionnant mais c'est
des pros et ils sont en train de nous
montrer il lâche rien et
avec cette attitude là ils vont ils vont
progresser quoi et du coup puis c'est
une science voilà de l'effort c'est
normal ce qu'on voit pour moi après oui
même pour eux Jordan est fatigué c'est
sûr
j'ai mal à la tête aussi
le gars le gars Jordan à la fin de
la partie Jordan très sympathique très
sympathique on le voit très
régulièrement avec son club de Clichy à
chaque à chaque top
et voilà c'est un joueur très accessible
il est bien tombé dans cette équipe de
petits chi qui est ma foi bien
sympathique et du coup je pense qu'il
passe des bons moments il fait la part
des choses mais en tout cas quand il est
sur l'échiquier il est focus voyez bien
là c'est un très très gros tournois donc
il est encore plus focus et il est à la
maison voilà
et cherche à poser des problèmes il
regarde notre roi E5
et
en fait je disais mais qu'est-ce qui
regarde parce que bon il y a tout B5 on
a vu c'est pas de problème les échecs
latéraux peut faire le test je pensais
qu'il était en train de regarder G5 il
vient de jouer pour prendre ces 7
et Aniche je vois tempo de toute façon
ils vont ils vont finalement jouer ce
qu'on avait vu enfin tout
juste on va revenir dessus de toute
façon c'est la limite on a regardé il y
avait peut-être un coup une dernière
chance ce roi G7 c'était le coup un peu
incroyable G5 et sur là je prends G5
maintenant tu prends ces 7
comme ça à Nice il a plus roi F6
à cause du mat je piquais la case en
fait tout il y a peut-être droit à un
schisme mais c'est quand même différent
maintenant toi à 7
G4
c'est un bon petit piège mais c'est un
peu raccro donc on va revenir sur la
partie c'était la ligne la plus logique
vous voyez le roi et Angers 5 de toute
façon
dernière leur dernier ajout de temps
exactement
bon là Aniche il y a tout prévu on voit
qu'il est pas inquiètes autour des 8 à
tempo
donc alors qu'on a la pression ici
il est un peu un peu embêté ici
je me fais embêter mon foot tout le
temps regardez c'est marrant ça
[Musique]
j'ai quand même poussé deux comme quoi
il y a toujours de la ressource
ouais bon très compliqué très très
compliqué surtout les tours des 6 avec
ça enfin tour C8 peut-être je sais pas
en tout cas c'est très très bordélique
mais à Nice il joue son va tout ici il
est obligé en fait il pouvait pas rester
là il pouvait pas rester dans cette
position il allait se prendre ces 7 et
être rapidement au fou des cinq même
dans de bonnes conditions ok
la tour que justement aller faire des
échecs comme ça exactement enfin après
il a fallu attendre la finale pour ça
mais
tout à fait
donc il y a eu un gros travail quand
même de Jordan van forest il a posé les
problèmes on se demandait qui jouait
pour le gain bah c'est lui de bout en
bout
grosse partie matador on a bien d'accord
avec toi
il va faussement tomber il va récupérer
le quart d'heure non vous inquiétez pas
c'est pas fini
il cherche une casse pour son roi et
puis c'est pas trop le ou le mettre quoi
parce qu'il y a pas de bonne case la
case la plus logique pour moi c'est le
jour où à C5
mais on a vu que ça gagnait pas
et c'est même dangereux
faut pas se faire cravater le fou il y a
quand même le pion à deux vous voyez un
peu les histoires
mais oui il y a la différence aussi
d'une partie où tu es où il y a des
parties on réfléchit beaucoup d'autres
moins partir où justement on est gagnant
d'autres noms et ça change énormément de
choses quand tu subis tu subis
pendant une partie pendant plusieurs
heures c'est terrible c'est terrible et
ça te fatigue beaucoup plus que c'était
à l'aise et parfois il suffit de faire
quelques coups pratiques et tout va bien
et d'autres fois non il faut il faut se
casser la tête pour pour trouver j'ai
envie de dire en plus il y a pas que les
super GM comme on voit là
[Musique]
il a trouvé roi C3
je pense qu'il va jouer ça
ils vont la jouer
la petite ligne Touareg 2 ou 42 vous ces
deux je pense que ça va être ça il
voulait cravater le pion à deux
donc moi c'est trois jouets
vous avez vu la jauge pour une fois à
indiquer un petit avantage noir après
avoir ces trois
c'est rigolo mais ça va faire nuit
et j'ai mal au très bien dit franchement
très très bien dit j'ai mal où et qu'à
la fin tu passes une nuit de merde en
plus on peut le dire comme ça j'ai mal
aux pas de souci
on a un petit peu fatigué normal
franchement à chaque fois qu'on fait des
grosses mais les on est comme les
joueurs voilà dans un autre registre
parce que nous on peut pas enfin si on
fait une connerie Laurie on peut
reprendre quoi notre couple la bonne
différence on n'a pas l'impression de
dire c'est pas grave
c'est vraiment différent
mais ouais c'est fatiguant et puis on
regarde un peu toutes les parties donc
on se casse les neurones forcément ton
rêve de faux 4 voilà c'est la partie
c'est très qualitatif encore aujourd'hui
je trouve que le niveau des parties
juste fou
peut-être que là sur les deux derniers
jours et à partir de Prague hier mais
alors là c'était pas bon du tout et
aujourd'hui il était un niveau
exceptionnel on peut le dire hier il y a
pas de content de lui du tout du tout du
tout
une non partie mais globalement au
niveau est constant quand ça perd digne
c'est un peu délité aujourd'hui dans le
zaynote et la partie des regga easy on
l'a laissé un petit peu de côté c'est
vrai
en tout cas la folka donc l'idée
on a plein de poussées etc le joueur en
face doit rester actif il doit nous
poser des problèmes tous deux c'est
logique et peut-être un petit poussé
deux pour cacher le fou quelque part
parce que sinon il se fait harceler le
fou et on visera le pion à deux en plus
tu peux pas faire rentrer ton tour
est-ce qu'on peut pas t'embêter
celle-là je voudrais la montrer
ça fait un peu peur parce que par
exemple tourner un
là je vais balancer mon pion je E7 je
pense
et là maintenant ce Piona inarrêtable et
je pourrais donner
ma tour sur la dame et tu me fais
quelques échecs je vais aller me cacher
voilà
quelque part
donc tous deux à niche il rate pas
l'occasion de se mettre derrière ce pion
passé
et le mettre en même temps la pression
comme ça sur 7
tours C8 et je contrôle les deux pions
passés
et si le fou bouge est même des tours
prend le 7 le riz tu sais parce que la
tour elle doit tenir le pion donc c'est
le bordel
on est proche donc vous avez tout prévu
jusqu'à fou ces deux forest
et là ils vise le pion mais il y a
plusieurs quoi actifs tour des 6 tours
C8 devant le pion la tour contrôle bien
ce qu'on a donc il va jouer contre ce
sur là maintenant c'est très logique
pour un gigari il va jouer assez vite je
pense soit pour C8 soit tour des 6 je
pense que c'est vraiment l'écoute très
très logique dans cette position assez
facile à trouver puisqu'il y a deux
dangers
ces deux pions là les deux Schtroumpfs
ils seront pas je trouve là ils sont
chauds
facile là pour lui là on devrait
assister à nul dans pas trop longtemps
je pense que je vois moins de ressources
pour les blancs
en plus assez change
que l'on se rapproche
encore les récupérer les pions
une faute et vite arrivée avec la
fatigue bon ils ont 15 minutes chacun
là c'est la fin c'est vraiment la fin il
faut pas craquer ouais je sais pas si
digne va gagner contre népaule les gens
pensent que digne est plus constant
c'est vrai mais sur un match de
championnat du monde le seul problème du
dernier match championnat du monde c'est
la constance de de Néo
il avait je disais Laurent hier qui
était plutôt d'accord très bien entamé
son cheval du monde puis après c'est
déliter complètement
donc
[Musique]
il a gagné les candidats de manière
assez brillante à chaque fois
et maintenant il faut qu'il gère son
match de championnat du monde si il y a
une partie Laurent nous disait ça hier
souvent n'est pas utile dès qu'il perd
une partie
bah écoutez il a juste à travailler
là-dessus il sait où est son point
d'interrogation technigment sera
quasiment même niveau il va travailler
il va se préparer je pense que si
l'effort psychologiquement moi je
mettrais bien une petite pièce sur une
épaule
j'entends trop de ding ding ding voilà
Ding il a du mal déjà donc on verra il
est encore trois mois pour se refaire
une santé je pense qu'il sera vraiment
en forme mais c'est quand même c'est
comme loin d'être fait pour des six qui
a été joué d'ailleurs tour des 6 normal
pressing
tour reprend à deux voilà et là on se
rapproche vraiment de la
parce que l'adversaire est très actif il
va manger
[Musique]
je pense que c'est pas une histoire de
cramer ses forces c'est qu'en fait il a
pas supporté de perdre cette partie qui
était hyper difficile à digérer il a
perdu là cette fois-ci c'est en 7h30
vous allez me dire mais on se rappelle
tous de cette partie et c'était horrible
c'est juste que pour le spectacle
qu'enseigne ne joue pas c'est quand même
dommage c'est vraiment le joueur qu'on
aime suivre il gagne tout est-ce qu'il
aurait été capable on aime bien avoir le
champion du monde c'est rare dans une
discipline que le Championnat du Monde
il se retire quoi ça existe mais c'est
un peu rageant quoi OK
attaque la tour de
est-ce qu'on peut encore jouer cette
position pour le gain avec les Blancs
oui on peut toujours aimer
les chaises n'ont pas l'air hyper
confortables tu penses politiques
semble avoir mal aux fessiers
apparemment
politique c'est ça
je pense pas je pense pas je pense qu'il
tient la route
ils ont envie de jouer les joueurs ils
ont envie d'en finir parce que là on se
rapproche de la nul il le savent tous
les deux
c'est difficile d'accepter même dans une
fin de partie
est-ce qu'on peut pas jouer alors faut
que je fasse gaffe au pire
parce que sinon j'aimerais bien aller
chercher le pion mais il va rester
il a joué tout âge de d'accord
c'est rigolo
OK
on note
est-ce que
le 7 est jouable je pense pas la dû le
regarder j'ai peut-être trop décidé
d'ailleurs et tout re de revient ouais
tout simplement le F6 voilà il y a pas
trop de risques c'est même dur de jouer
un coup à gle et blanc
on sait que c'est égal ce genre de
position mais
faut pas faire n'importe quoi
ça paraît d'ailleurs risquer d'échanger
une tour ce qu'on peut échanger une tour
comme ça
j'aimerais bien garder la Tour Blanche
encore nul mais le roi bien placé ça
serait quand même inconfortable
je vais pour voir
le roi soit assez proche des grosses
position de travail pour pour les ah oui
non mais trois en plus c'est vraiment la
cata parce qu'il y a ça
c'est pas très malin
c'est un peu bizarre quand même j'ai
envie de voir juste cette position ce
que j'ai le droit faut bien faire encore
nulle
ça ça
mais il va revenir avec le fou des cinq
feux F3 bon c'est vrai que c'est une
sorte de forteresse avec les gens faut
pas exagérer bon delà ce qui joue fou B1
Dordogne c'est un peu étonnant il a pas
il doit avoir plus actif comme un
donc ça paraît logique de faire tourner
6 et chaque
joueur des si ça marche pas du tout
ah bah non je suis bête le 3
on n'arrête pas le pion ça c'était un
bon coup de fiche il a pas jouer ça il
va pas jouer ça du tout à Nice
donc je peux jouer tour C8 voilà
tranquille comme je voulais faire au
départ c'était bien mieux
surtout pas tourner 6
pas de blague
je suis concentré
et maintenant on va signer bientôt
il y a plusieurs façons de faire nul ici
on peut bouger à tour maintenant et
après
il y a plusieurs nuls peut-être
si je veux faire nul avec les Blancs
c'est relativement simple pour ça tu me
prends ici
et je fais dames
est-ce que ça te va le riz comme nul on
va vérifier
ce que toi ça je me souviens
donc il y a l'histoire de la dame donc
on prend plutôt comme ça
je fais dames pour prendre
ce qui était bons amis
on va bouffer un pion chacun machin
maintenant de Jordan
c'est un peu plus précis cependant
parce qu'il va intercaler un tour G6
c'est mieux ce qui fait quand même pas
toujours les problèmes si je prends le
fou E8 dames
tours
et là je fais échec pour ça qu'il a mis
en a si c'est plus précis que toi à 7
que j'ai proposé rapidement c'est la
même config au moins je peux garder donc
là je vais faire WAF 4 je pense pour
rester
près du pion reprends-tours et la H5 nul
je vérifie quand même pour pas faire de
bêtises voilà voilà comment ça va se
finir
à chaque pour liquider Laurie d'éliter
la structure voilà au final du squelette
on éclate le squelette
je pense
du coup ça Achille on va récupérer mon
option h
donc c'est plus précis toi racisme et
c'est rien du tout Annie tu vas voir ça
très très vite et je vous dis qu'on va
avoir une nulle dans les cinq prochaines
minutes
est-ce que tu as l'affichage des scores
aussi ou pas
alors l'affichage des scores est-ce que
tu veux que je fasse un petit point
classement en attendant
je peux pas les afficher Je peux pas les
afficher
passe nul pour le suspense tournoi et il
va être seul deuxième le Poulidor du
tournoi et pour l'instant encore
deuxième avant la dernière ronde
et je pense qu'il va être en obligation
de gagner demain
donc Abdou 8 qui va avoir 7 et demi
Magnus 7 points
ce serait très étonnant qui reviennent à
tout va pas perdre demain je pense pas
ça peut mais ok la très faible difficile
et après ben voilà on voit que tous les
habitués mine de rien sont au première
loge il y a juste une des pépites qui a
réussi à se glisser si vous voulez dans
le haut du tableau et à la première
place ça nous ça t'auras finalement à
partir de la huitième passe passe pardon
on a max zoodlu on a Prague nana on a
bucket donc c'est normal et on a aussi
malheureusement digne des rennes pour
lui onzième pas terrible on a Vincent
Kemer van Forest et regaizi qui ferme la
marche
ça a tout joué ça ajoute du tempo voilà
il rigole ils ont souri ils son copain
enfin ils sont voilà ils sont foutus sur
la tronche voilà ils font des petits
guilis maintenant voilà niche et il
rigole vent de Forest c'est un peu vert
parce que il la pressait mais c'est lui
qui a le plus voilà
parce que qu'est-ce qui peut jouer ici
il va pas il y aura des trois ou rien
donc là c'est juste que c'est un peu dur
et puis bon
un poulet Poulidor et chaque il y a
Mulhouse Poulidor et chaque aussi non
mais oui
c'était un cycliste qui faisait tout le
temps deuxième voilà donc il a fini 5
fois 2e de ce tournoi du tata style gris
et il est très très bien parti pour
confirmer sa sa place de deuxième encore
cette année
c'est beau de confirmer une telle place
il aime la deuxième place
pourquoi à joli
papouille voilà ils sont voilà c'est
compatriote il se foutent sur la tronche
pendant toute la partie grosse prépa il
dit ouais tu m'as foutu la tronche voilà
tu fais bien les voir et bien prépa
ouais tu m'as fait du mal tu as failli
me banane mon roi
c'était chaud
et du coup guéri a dû voir des pauses
qu'il aurait bien fait à la place de
Jordan parce qu'à un moment il emmenait
pas l'argent
[Musique]
est-ce que vous voulez voir
le tableau des scores
je vais le demander
allez en anglais
je vais demander le petit tableau des
scores pour vous voyez bien donc demain
c'est à midi le stream n'oubliez pas
[Musique]
pour la dernière ronde donc ça ça promet
un beau stream du coup grâce à guéri
parce que il aurait perdu là
franchement il y avait un point d'écart
avec Abdou qui allait faire sa petite
nul avec les Blancs et voilà on remet
quoi
là ça sera ça sera dur donc
j'ai demandé le
cas d'égalité je vous le dis en cas
d'égalité c'est match de partage
ça nous amène au bout de la nuit
je l'ai vu déjà ce match de départage
mais en tout cas
si inégalité les deux premiers
s'affrontent donc on peut avoir
on peut avoir un joli match avec deux
jours à 6 girigan demain
un Cornetto c'est toujours bon moment
plein hiver je lui dira flotteur demain
je sais plus en fait comme j'ai dit je
vérifierai pour demain il faudrait
demain
à midi
et du coup mon score board pour
l'instant je l'ai pas trop eu
sinon tu vas à l'oral mais
moi je peux vous le refaire mais
en gros la première place se joue à
demain sera pas comme ça
je vais tenter ça
on a tous les scores si vous voulez 8-7
et demi mais j'aimerais bien enregistrer
mais j'ai pas la main donc
donc ouais super super parfait 5 Vanessa
vous avez aimé le petit accent anglais
donc
il est premier avec 8 points suivis
d'Aniche 7 et demi ça se joue entre deux
mains
du coup on a Carl seneso à 7 points qui
jouent pas grand chose ok il faut gagner
demain mais à Blue va pas perdre et
voilà bon c'est vraiment le mauvais spot
pour eux
donc demain je pense que pour le coup ça
va jouer très fort chez
Abdou et guéri j'aurais bien aimé les
périmes maintenant je vais demander
donc du coup en direct puisque le reste
du classement c'est pas que ça vous
intéresse moi mais c'est pas l'effet
c'est pas l'effet marquant
donc du coup on va regarder je pense que
Vanessa va pouvoir nous afficher
les appareils
et oui je peux dire que à chaque fois
que
ma maman m'entend parler anglais elle
essaie de
d'oublier qu'elle a été prof d'anglais
et voilà donc ça c'est c'était les
scores de la journée
voilà
donc vous voyez voilà deux parties
décisives mais les gros devant
c'est c'est vraiment
des matchs nuls donc ça n'a rien changé
ça n'a fait que confirmer
ce que l'on attendait c'est à dire une
dernière ronde décisive avec un demi
point d'écart entre le 2 grands
animateurs le jeune d'où ça t'auras qui
a dominé de bout en bout et anis guéri
qui a été hyper dangereux demain vous
voyez ce qu'on aura n'en voyez pas ok je
vais vous les je voulais donner pour
demain
je les ai pas sous les yeux donc va
falloir que je les cherche
tac
surprise
je pensais que je les aurais mais je
sais pas voilà du coup OK
je fais les chercher par moi-même mais
jamais mis servi vous avez le droit dans
le chat de les mettre
dans 30 secondes dans 30 secondes OK
donc moi je peux vous les autres non je
peux vous les donner oralement
si je les ai là hop
je fais sur le site officiel ça prend un
petit peu de temps
une recherche si j'avais mis la page
avant
c'est parti donc de coup
s
de Forest merci Arnaud pour la
réactivité
encore meilleur parce que Arnaud
normalement est très performant voilà
on vous remercie en tout cas pour ce
stream et votre bienveillance dans le
chat de votre participation comme à
chaque fois
demain on espère qu'il y aura un petit
peu moins de coupure c'est vrai que
normalement ça devrait être devrait être
OK
Fatou merci beaucoup pour ta
participation j'espère que tu as
apprécié ce stream
donc c'était c'était cool on se retrouve
demain j'ai déjà dit à midi avec Mathieu
cornette on aura l'occasion de toute
façon de se retrouver avec la team
chasse comme fr durant d'autres tournois
mais en tout cas demain c'est le grand
dénouement donc on va on va vous quitter
on va demander simplement un Vanessa de
de fermer les streams et on va se
retrouver dès demain pour la suite
merci à tous en tout cas une excellente
journée très très bientôt bonne soirée à
tous un demain bien sûr à demain pour la
fin bye bye bye merci Fatou en tout cas
et merci à tout le monde dans le chat on
vous souhaite une très très bonne soirée
un bon samedi soir
[Musique]